interesting
very very interesting
guys captain Holt has no pants on Oh
what he has no pants on is what here are
the facts at 11:55 a.m. captain Holt
walked past us holding a hot bowl of
soup at 12:03 p.m. I heard him yell out
then at 12:07 he called Gina into his
office she entered holding nothing one
minute later she left holding an opaque
bag captain Holt's pants were in that
bag his knees are in the breeze he's in
his undies that evidence is
circumstantial
oh so you guys want visual confirmation
no really done hey captain I just need
you to sign something at my desk real
quick just leave it on the couch
dismissed okay sir you're gonna freak
yo-yo ma is in the precinct he's giving
out autographs yo-yo Ma's on tour in
Australia right now how would you know
that I'm choking on a lawsuit I'm gonna
die hey I made you another bowl of soup
since you spilled yours earlier but
you're gonna have to come over here to
get it all right parole comes to be
wasting time so yes I spilled some
minestrone on my pants and I'm sitting
in my underwear happy ah sir I need you
to sign off on look at us just three
people with pants on having a normal
conversation yep no story here
you